a powerful painkiller called fentanyl is
responsible for one of the deadliest
drug crises in American history believed
to be the leading cause of death
for Americans 18 to 45. think about that
it kills people who don't even know that
they're taking it that's what's so scary
more than 150 people per day in these
United States die from synthetic opioid
overdoses and it takes only a tiny tiny
amount to kill someone CBS Evening News
anchor and managing editor Nora
O'Donnell met a family touched by this
crisis and they are now working to keep
other young people safe
Landon Hausman was a popular basketball
star and at 16 years old he took a
fentanyl laced Percocet pill and died
sometimes with fentanyl you don't get a
second chance beautiful beautiful sun
sadly Landon's story is All Too common
last year more than 100
000 Americans died from an overdose the
majority from fentanyl a nearly
invisible poison did Landon have a sense
that he could be buying a pill that
would be laced with fentanyl I don't
think he even recognized that that was
going to be a possibility
in January the Maryland high school
sophomore bought pills from a dealer
through social media no longer are we
talking about meeting on the street and
making that connection the dealer is in
your kid's pocket along with the phone
Deputy attorney general Lisa Monaco
oversees the Drug Enforcement
Administration and says this is the
dea's top priority there were more
deaths from fentanyl last year than from
the wars in Vietnam Afghanistan and Iraq
combined why isn't this a national
security crisis I think it is Nora I
think it's a national security issue I
think it's a public safety issue I think
it's a public health issue this drug is
man-made it's mass produced it's done in
largely in illicit labs in Mexico where
the drug cartels are manufacturing from
chemicals precursor chemicals that come
from companies We Believe largely from
China they're pressing these pills and
they're making them look like legitimate
prescription drugs things like percocet
or Adderall or xanax but they're not
deaths among teens have tripled and in
the last year the DEA says it is
investigating more than 120 cases that
involves social media they even issued a
warning of emoji code language dealers
use to Target young buyers these are
unsuspecting users thinking they're
getting one thing and they're getting
something else in the form of fentanyl
so those really that's not actually an
overdose Nora that's a poisoning why
isn't there a Crackdown by the justice
department on these social media
companies we're talking to the social
media companies and frankly
we're asking them that to do more they
need to do more they need to be policing
their platforms to detect those drug
dealers that are on those platforms and
pushing it out to kids so they need to
use quite frankly the same tools and the
technology that allows them to
exquisitely serve up those ads for all
sorts of things that we're buying online
and identify those drug dealers and
getting them off the dealer who sold the
fake Percocets to land in is facing
federal charges but for housemen just
one arrest isn't enough what does
Justice look like to you I can't go back
and change what happened but what I can
do is try to do everything possible so
maybe this doesn't happen to someone
else for CBS mornings I'm Nora O'Donnell
in Washington
really do applaud that father for
speaking up when he's in so much pain
but this is scary your kids think
they're ordering one thing and then they
get something else that's deadly yeah I
like how Lisa described it not an
overdose it's a poison it's a poison uh
and then the the idea that the drug
dealer is not somebody at the front door
or a playground but in your kitchen
right in their bedroom as a parent you
don't know yeah so that's why we have to
check in on our kids that's why I'm a
big proponent of Parental snooping there
you go there's nothing wrong with that I
plead guilty but those days are over
those are over for me